you
hello everybody welcome to the 17th
machine learning for the use of
automated trading and algorithmic
trading where we left off we were
drawing that plot up
we made the predictions of you know
basically uh past patterns where did
they go and then we saw where it really
went and where our prediction was and
whether or not we were right or wrong so
far we've been right every time now I
don't really suspect that it will always
be the case right but pretty nice and is
certainly helpful enough to get us to
push forward so now we need to consider
it a few things though we really need to
back test this now that said if you
played with the data enough you realize
that in its current form plot to plot or
point to point even if you don't plot
it's very slow so just running through
storing patterns comparing patterns at
every plot with our current processing
time a fullback test of this one month
of this kind of tick data that we have
this interest second kind of stuff if
you do the math will land you at about
one year of processing time now there's
there's quite a few viable solutions to
fixing that problem the issue of our
processing is really mostly because
Python is a single threaded or it's
Python single threaded nature right so
natively Python simply is a linear
programming language so it's not capable
of what's called parallel programming so
can't do multiple calculations at the
same time right you can do threading
quote/unquote threading with Python but
natively you really can't so anyway so
there's a few thats the issue and
there's a few solutions so here are a
few solutions one you can leave Python
and you could get Java or C or C
something right and or you can just
simply you keep Python but call up C for
the pattern kind of stuff right so you
for this you can either do that or you
can even use something like scythe on or
Jai thon which is kind of like the
meshing of Python and either Java or C
- you can simulate the threading on your
own and so I'll show you guys an example
of this towards the end here so what you
can do like let's say for example your
average processing time is 20 seconds so
what you would need to do then since we
have inter second data you would really
need to pull up 20 Python windows and
for every second you perform your
calculation in that Python window and
then everything just convenes in a
similar database right a shared database
and in this sense that's as good as as
threading as you can hyper threading or
or parallel programming as you'll get
natively with Python and this isn't
really that bad of a method it's just if
you're just you have to account for that
20-second delay but the benefit here of
course is that after a month you're not
you know when you're backlogged right so
so there's that number three you can use
CUDA CUDA is a way to utilize your GPU
or your graphics card for processing now
obviously you're going to need it what's
called a CUDA enabled processor
otherwise basically meaning NVIDIA GPUs
usually higher-end NVIDIA GPU to do this
and if you are interested you I might
actually do a video or a few videos on
doing this kind of thing in the future
but again you will need an Nvidia CUDA
enabled GPU and then for we could also
change the time frame of the data right
honestly we probably don't need to be
using intra second tick data you can
probably do this with really just even
just a little bit better at one minute
open high low close data right using the
closed numbers and that would cut down
our data significantly right 60 times
smaller so that would be pretty helpful
it would cut down on the amount of
patterns in the time frame as well it's
really it's not the size of the file
right 50 kilobytes or 50 sorry it's 50
megabytes I think for the one month
that's not too bad once it's read into
memory but the problem is the amount of
patterns that that makes right and yeah
it's just a ton of patterns
so anyway obviously processing time is a
bit of an issue now the next thing that
we can kind of consider though is not
only can we do some of the things above
we can also for one only load in the
full list of data once instead of
loading it in every times right now
we're doing it every time just to fully
simulate an unknown scenario but that
wouldn't you wouldn't really need to be
the case you could you know run in store
patterns only once every day like once a
day and do it and that way you were only
sacrificing a few minutes or you can do
it even once a week right so the markets
do closed so you can do that now and
also really in this entire script here
there's a lot of things that we can do
to clean it up so there are definitely a
lot of things that you can do as I kind
of mentioned earlier I'm mostly I'm here
to kind of teach you the theory and the
principles and show you that it does
indeed work not really here I mean
people get paid large very large
salaries to do this kind of thing and so
I'm not really looking to do that for
you so anyway unless you want to pay me
a very large salary then we can talk so
there's ask now anyway so back test I
think is an option we definitely want to
do it but we should probably thread this
back test and because one I mean I think
after looking at her data from the
visual results we can see that one for
sure pattern recognition part is working
and two it does appear to be successful
right in predicting the future outcomes
so we definitely want to back test it so
we need to build something to actually
back test this so so what we want to do
is do that and then what I what I think
we'll do is after we build this to back
test it I'll show you the results I will
just write it myself you can also thread
it also it's very simple to do it so at
least in the way that I'm doing it so
we'll thread it and then you can
actually see the results I ran for about
800 it'll be about 900 to 1000 results
each one and then add it up would be
8,000 results how accurate were we every
step of the way so pretty interesting
stuff going forward and in the next
video we'll be setting up the back
testing and then I'll show you the
results of that back testing
so anyway that's going to do this video
as always thanks for watching